gender and sexuality they're more
complicated than you might think so
we're here to break down some terms that
you might not know about pansexuality
refers to people who are attracted to
people regardless of their gender
identity or biological sex then there's
a sexuality so that's when you don't
experience sexual attraction or are
uninterested in sexual activity if
sexual people may choose to pursue a
romantic relationship without the
physical components or they may prefer
to remain single but identity isn't just
about who you date it's about who you
are and for some people that's not as
simple as male or female cisgender
people are those whose identity matches
the gender they were assigned at birth
it's what most people think of when they
say gender transgender people are people
whose identity don't match the one that
they were assigned at birth and they may
or may not have surgery to get their
body in line with their identity but the
gender box is getting even bigger gender
fluid and genderqueer people identify as
two or more genders and may move between
masculine and feminine presentations all
these words can be dizzying and we're
just scratching the surface but in the
end it's simple you do you
you